Yeah.
And now,
you know,
with bill,
she's 16 and now we have
motion one oh three,
the nts homophobia bill and then the
whole child and family services act has
been now changed to a bill 89.
And uh,
basically if your child,
if Jimmy comes home and
identifies as a girl,
um,
and do you kind of,
you know,
talk them out of it or saying it in a no.
Uh,
you could have cs at your doorstep.
Hold off on the puberty delay,
uh,
hormones there,
Kiddo.
You might change your mind.
Yeah.
You could keep your breasts for a while
and chased you decide that you're wrong.
I consider this child abuse as a form
of child protection worker for eight
years.
To me this is a flat out child abuse
that's being sanctioned by the state.
And uh,
what I'm really surprised about is that
more and more parents aren't speaking
out about this.
They dropped their litter with a movement.
There are terrified.
Like the teachers are terrified.
Serena,
there's going to be lawsuits
Galore in 15 years though,
that's for sure.
These kids who from whom
consent is being derived,
despite the fact that there
have no age to provide consent,
are going to be a vicious
legal protagonists when
they go after the physicians
and,
and other authorities who've made
these reprehensible decisions.
I wanted to talk to you briefly vote the
law society and about what's happening
recently,
the doctors and the law society.
Uh,
and basically the issues that you
were talking with in predicting.
Now we see them come true.
Okay.
So,
uh,
when the loss,
see I think that the Law
Society of Ontario will
succeed in its pushed to make a
statement of principles reflecting
social justice ideology mandatory.
I think they're going to win that.
Um,
I think there will be lawyers
who will refuse to write it,
that will take them to court and then
it'll be dragged out for a long time.
But,
um,
as soon as the law society capitulates
are soon as the lawyers capitulate,
which they show virtually
every sign of doing that,
every professional organization and
counted is going to follow suit.
I don't know if you saw the agenda episode
where Steve Pakan had a whole panel
of lawyers on it.
They were talking about this.
No,
I didn't see it.
It just,
uh,
it was actually quite recent.
I'd say maybe the last two,
three weeks,
but you should look it
up and you're right.
They have capitulated.
Like,
it was pretty obvious to me that
this is where we're headed right.